okay I decided to get on a little early
here just to make sure we don't have any
problems I see we have zero viewers Oh
18 viewers all right 15 years all right
well I'm going to start in two minutes
but because I'm a little bit concerned
not used to this technology just wanna
get started early a new message okay
that's something flashed on slack I'm
not quite sure what that was all about
see all right doesn't matter all right
we're getting da circuit I guess we can
talk in general terms it was very rainy
yesterday in Palm Springs but today is a
sunny day this morning while making
breakfast and then again while cleaning
up afterwards I did a lot of listening
to Farsi and explained in the broadcast
just how that connects with what I do
please feel free to make comments or ask
questions these are going to be passed
on to me and then I'll try to reply to
them and and since this is a new
experiment for us any advice or
suggestions on how to make it better or
whatever please don't hesitate and we're
now one minute away from launching here
so we'll see what happens
who else says we'll see what happens I'm
trying to remember
okay
it is ten o'clock Pacific Standard Time
and different times in different parts
of the world and this is the first ever
online language workout I'm not quite
sure how it's going to turn out but I
have had in mind is that I'm gonna be
studying Arabic and farsi I'll probably
do Farsi on Fridays and Arabic on Monday
and Wednesday so every three times a
week Monday and Wednesday will be Arabic
Friday will be Farsi it doesn't matter
what language you are learning I'm gonna
be doing Arabic and farsi and I'm gonna
be sharing with you what I do to work on
those languages so it's a kind of a
space where we hang out we get together
I'm gonna have in my mind that three
times a week at 10 o'clock I have to
show up and I have to study Farsi and
Arabic and so perhaps you can treat it
as that way if you have the time to do
it at 10 o'clock Pacific Standard Time
or you simply come by the YouTube
channel
whenever you do have the time and so
that we study together
I think that's the main purpose every
one of us is gonna have a slightly
different approach to learning languages
or a different approach to using link
and I'm hoping to learn from you as well
because you may suggest things that I
can do you may see things that I do that
are beneficial to you so without further
ado I'm gonna share my screen and I'm
gonna you know behave as if I was just
sitting down to study with Lane one
other thing I should say is that I
normally use my iPad and every so often
I'll mix the computer learning with the
iPad learning to give you a sense of how
they differ but it's essentially the
same but it's just that I might be a
little less familiar with working with
our the browser version that I am with
the the iPad version
okay now I'm going to share my screen
with you
so screen share
now I am assuming that you can now see
my screen hopefully that's the case if
it's not the case someone in my office
will let me know so if I look at my
screen here this is my Farsi I can
change as you know to Arabic there any
other language but it's my fart screen
and I just before I got into my studying
I just thought I would show you a couple
of things one is if I go to my profile
and so you will see that the bulk is
where I'm not looking at known words the
last seven days but if I look at all
time you will see that I really bumped
up my activity in December so prior to
that I had an initial brief exploration
of Farsi and but then I spent most of my
time on Arabic in preparation from a
trip to Morocco but then when I came
back from Morocco I've really stepped up
my Farsi learning and of course you can
go to your profile and you could look at
different time periods and different you
know issues links created you'll see
that the bulk of my link creation
activity was in here so that's kind of
an indication of my history with Farsi I
got initially turned on because I was in
Montreal and bought a book and so I
explored it a bit but really it's in the
last of the while that I've started
focusing on my Farsi so that was one
thing I wanted to show you the other
thing I wanted to show you was that if I
go to my lessons no I want to show you
play this so the playlists are a big
part of my learning and whenever I study
a lesson at link I download it to a
playlist so that I can listen to it
wherever I am and you'll see that these
this
our mini story series sorry what I'd
listen to 52 times 44 and attends to as
I work my way down my playlist the part
this is who is she
62 times but lesson one and who is she
it generally declines and then as I can
only have unfortunately a hundred items
in your playlist and then you have to
delete some to make room for others but
you know this is like the most recent
story that I listened to this morning in
fact stories 60 in the many stories I've
only listened to three types so I have a
tremendous tolerance for listening to
things over and over again that may not
be the case with everyone all right now
let's go to my lessons and since I
mentioned less than 60 let's go to the
mini stories and I'll show you what I
would do
so I was 100 another thing is when I'm
deciding what to study I often look at
how many yellow words there are because
if you're if I'm reviewing some a lesson
that I've listened to many many times I
may just go through that's as an example
it's just openness it says that there
are 14 saved yellow links and we'll wait
for it to come up here and now that we
can hide this guy because we know that
we're joining a live workout so
sometimes rather than reading through
the story which I've read many times and
I've listened to many times I just will
do this I will just look at the words
that are phrases that I have saved
because I still not fully comfortable
that I know so you know I would go
through these so let's do that so
unfortunately we don't have
text-to-speech in Farsi so whole silly
ash pasola ash is bored am i doing the
pronunciation wrong but submit okay next
be be be be I think I don't know be I
think that's just part of something else
maybe take particle know without okay
next shall not come condition let's see
Shan Shan Shan know cannot condition
oconee should knock on it may be drink I
don't know
flip it swim okay so I go through these
know now continue doing it now read it
as I would normally do be or solely be
hustling board okay what you're allowed
neither whole soul and mood or solely
mood how many do I am afraid
in fact I'm gonna go through these as if
you people aren't looking over my
shoulder I'm just too afraid I am afraid
Hmong as of meetha meetha Shum that's
what I am afraid I am afraid right okay
okay um all goes for year or horse goes
ye horse
mazi nice okay so delicious yeah I might
flip the car yeah see I don't normally
because I haven't I should I know me
don't go into the language so a reader
settings review settings the verse
flashcard no because I can't I just
don't
I find it too difficult I just like to
be exposed to it so I'm lazy so close
horse mozzie is tasty oh Sh mozzie clip
delicious sacred is the title of the
book let's see now
now host is first of all now hostess
the law then horse halt horse all is
happy no is happy next me Todd shot is a
me scared
Sami Sami lava Sameera I mean about
sodomy robot hmm I can't remember is
going sorry about okay
so I don't remember that either
no no driver that when I guess on these
next show nod Shannon swear maybe Shanna
next Tasha is afraid shut I can maybe
move that up now I've seen it a couple
of times
horse mozzie is delicious horse mozzie I
wish my see next is now horse is first
okay let's see that what fall is happy
okay it's getting a bit better now meet
our shot afraid scared
okay bow will give myself credit for
that one sorry meet a lot is going okay
and okay next afternoon I'm not really
familiar with that one at all flip the
card now here at the present okay and
leave it there as a to Shana is part of
the work and not is to swim and in
session complete so once I've completed
it then what I would do is go read
through it now because we don't have
text to speech in Farsi I would read
through it listening does Tony
say Corran yet good whip you hold me
over at chorim don mihalick or vaahana
whistle ash Sameera baat kar raha rules
take your neck or not we exciting you
dreaded me hot no host Oh Simon cannot
or has equal not a moccasin East a
moccasin East is equal not a moccasin
East because it's easy to repeat you've
heard it continue national cannot us
sigh Makwana channel cannot meet her set
couldn't that Hornet yes my cozy hey
vana so I'm gonna stop here because so I
wanted to go to number sixty which is
gonna be much more difficult so I would
go back to my lessons my lessons I could
have actually gone to the course itself
and open and I go down to number sixty
now this is gonna be a lot more
difficult because this is one that I've
only heard quite interesting that
because it's been a while since I did
lesson three I forget things that I knew
and and it doesn't matter because in
real life I might might need a whole
bunch of other words and so gradually
this stuff starts to stick it never
never bothers me alright so here I have
58 I've been through it once I have 58
reviewed names that's too far too many
to go through so what I tend to do here
is go and
Oh Santa suit because with sentence view
it's a lot easier to work on something
that's that's difficult now let me just
see here we had a question so if I can
have a look at the question it's the
second one where is it question so any
doesn't remember going up in there tones
I seem to be able to remember the words
do you have for teaching rather than
learning have you ever tried to use
languages to earn money as a translator
okay very quickly remember you woke up
no special advice the link system lots
of listening reading and just follow
what I'm doing in these I tend to review
the words the flashcards just before
just after a lesson with regard to
teaching I would I'll leave that as a
separate subject maybe I'll do a video
on it earn money as the translator no
but when I was about to create
Commission as a businessman I often had
to translate yeah have I changed the way
I work as far as know I tend to I just
haven't done it in the site for so long
but I tend to want everything up front
so I start reviewed to me is just
exposure I don't want to be wracking my
brain what I normally be saying about
luck you know what I wouldn't and I
wouldn't read out loud but in test
driving what I would do I started
reading out loud and then maybe is
something that I would do I mean I think
we're always finding new ways to do
things so yeah that's a possibility that
I would do that so here we are it's now
less than 60 so so I could firstly don't
have text to speech but does step Dustin
Dustin shed song 60 68 lesson so I could
do that on my own
read out loud in the stone as as zabun
shot horizontal
pull no blood nah-nah glee as Dustin as
the urban furrows Zod nada me shabbat
k-chat me cannot on em Rouge boron boy
out okay tough toe Spanish a stone in
Gaston as a bonus shot knocking miss
Shabbat shake me cannot andrew spotted
bi yet born beer so a person asked me if
I would normally leave read out loud
it's not something that I have in the
habit of doing but maybe it's something
that I will do more of this is Aleph
okay okay man effective econom Ambrose
mum mum can ask boredom be aura okay
chunky Don Osmond and bro Hawaii Tori
for you Dorrit so obviously struggling
to read this but I do understand it
unless Mike McConnell and remove
chemists bottom the bar at chunky
they're awesome on up for you College
what you start at punk it h mikonam and
I just discovered something that might
be quite useful because with the
five-second replay it's easy to go back
and find this sentence so if you're in
sentence view you can listen to the
sentence or parts of the sentence and
then try to repeat I would love it's not
something that I have been doing any I
think this is quite effective actually
so let's let's try that again Mike
mikonam Andrew smokin aspirin before at
manic mikonam Andrew smoked chemists
bottom before that man fact McCallum M
Rouge smoking as boron me boy yeah I
like it so much continued Schanke
they're awesome on up for your college
what you start at chunky there are some
on up for your college what you start at
chunky da awesome on a bra he 30 what
you thought up I didn't do that very
well let's do it again
chunky their awesome on up for your
college project are at John Kane or
someone boy Oberon he 30 would you
thought let's try it one more time okay
awesome on up for Utah Beach what you
got out there awesome on up high a party
would you do that okay good enough now I
know all the words here is I'm not gonna
lock them up in fact for example a Tony
come not so sheriff dark okay the boron
I know so I could move that to known
because one thing I like to do is I like
to make my page whiter and whiter as I
go along so boron mmm be bored on before
not have already forgotten you see so to
cover and that was from my previous so I
can go back I'm in no hurry here
go back Mike McConnell em Joe smoke
chemists bottom before at what on the
bottom bottom Denver out so why would
that be and see what that says to rain
so if you put the two them together it
means to rain alright so sometimes you
know first time through I'm saving words
in the next
might be saving a phrase so let's go
back to the beginning here again man
hates mikonam Andrews mechanists bar on
the bar at man hates mikonam Andrew
smoked chemists bottom before that man
technique on Ambrose monk in us-born
vibora okay so this is the sky and still
not totally with that clouds I borrow a
Bordeaux yee-hoo yee-hoo yee-haw t-tauri
voodoo Torah okay go on the next page
here chunky awesome on up for you told
you that I got a pretty good job ha ha I
can't bought on now yet but I got bought
on call you Tata Georgie's daughter okay
here just to make sure I know what
what's happening here ha ha
oh yeah I got a board on boy
boy yo nah now your now yo eat if it
doesn't rain Bora bent on back to us
better to backdoor us chitara chitara
row my umbrella
okay so the suggestion here is that I
will be answering questions in the
following videos you can ask questions
in social media and I will be answering
them throughout the workouts okay so now
so chapter on checked around
I'll get the pronunciation properly when
I go through it again
chitara bow khuddam for myself
boffo down bottle bottom door takeaway
bar Durham okay as as enjoy as enjoy ek
as enjoy kay somewhere else where are
you as enjoy okay the rules okay Ruth
goes are stay that was the previous day
mom he's has a shadow
okay now let's hear them say that you
that haha I can't bar on now yet
hamburger I bar on now your daughter
okay hold on you know I just thought of
something I shouldn't perhaps be reading
his out loud because it serves disturbs
other people who are who are studying
when learning Chinese characters a
better ended by levels
okay Chinese characters I started out
learning the first thousand and
thereafter I just learned them as I
found them okay yeah you can cheer
fluency without some sort of immersion I
mean eventually you have to do a lot of
time
after a question after doing all the
minister picks would you the upper
beginner or lower intermediate I'm not
sure what the difference is but you've
still got a long way to go
however the mini stories do focus on the
most common verbs and to that extent
it's very good for getting you into
talking I'm going to be talking to a
farsi tutor at 11:00 and i'm talking
much much earlier in farsi than I did in
say check
even though Farsi is completely
unrelated to any language I've never
learned since a completely unrelated but
not as closely related as check was to
Russian and a new Russian that took a
long time with checks one thing I want
to show before I leave today is let's go
back to my lessons here and so there I
was reviewing first of all a lesson that
I had done that had listened to many
many times and went back to an old
lesson so to speak then I went to a more
recent one that I've only listened to
three times or so but now I want to go
to you know I also like to do stuff
where I'm creating links so here is
something that I found online this is a
website called Persian online it's got a
lot of content that I import and if
there is any interest I can show you how
I go about importing this but I have it
here and so there are three levels this
is level three of Persian online and so
I've been through one is a brief
discussion of Iran Persian language and
then the Persian Gulf not here I have
lots of blue words and so I'll just show
you that and I'll do it quietly so I've
already gone through the first few
sentences here so come on
Hailee's Feli collegiate golf leave
farsi hadoo hadoo roughly house get
confused 85 I guess kilo metro bah these
are ease what is that it why okay Elise
re studying is the widest okay or while
wider widest 13 joke joke - what about
is that segment okay
as t9 kilo meter Wow um that's okay so
as you'll see here I go through
initially trying to convert the because
if I look at it in the total full-text
version you'll see that there are a lot
of blue words but there's also a lot of
white words and those lots of yellow
words I'm never shy about moving white
words back to yell but I could go
through this as well just doing the blue
words sometimes I do this I'm gonna go
through here and I'm just gonna hit the
blue words to get them out of the way so
islands have a second numerous and I'm
just hitting the arrow key own are
included and if this I presume is a name
obviously a name nothing makes it okay
if something like this that doesn't seem
to mean anything I might look it up in a
dictionary going to Google Translate
which is really the best for Farsi
unfortunately so there's no better
translation I'm presuming that's a name
sometimes if I'm not sure I'll go to the
sentence view and see what Google tries
says okay so the most important of them
are bla bla bla bla bla and that tells
them that these are all names so I don't
worry about it on LaVon I guess it's
also a name yeah so that those are names
so and I will very often flip back and
forth between sentence view and and the
page view because the page you in terms
of going through and very quickly
getting rid of the blue words or even
this way it's the blue and the yellow so
I'm just looking at words here I don't
know why it skip this one centigrade
okay centigrade mm-hmm passion now that
doesn't seem right passion and look it
up what do they offer excitement frenzy
sensation emotion okay so that obviously
I'm gonna have to save that after when I
actually get into the text and try to
understand it and then we'll pick
something that fits okay you know this
is our first my first attempt at doing
this I'm gonna limit it to half an hour
I'm gonna wrap it up here if there are
any other questions one thing I was
thinking I might do at some point is
maybe record a conversation with my
tutor both in Farsi and in Arabic and
then put it up and you we can see if
during the three month period I improve
or not my experience is that the
speaking improves slowly but the
quantity of words that we acquire
increases significantly okay do we have
any other questions before I wrap up
suggestions on what I might do
differently now let's see if I can get
back to stop okay Here I am again so
yeah any questions suggestions what we
might do the next one will be on Arabic
it'll be on Monday let me know if you
think this is used
Oh advice and what to do better things
that you do at link that are different
that might be helpful to me and yeah
that's it we are now 10:30 thank you for
listening see you next time here's a
question do you use link in your
advanced languages I'm not working on my
advanced languages however if I find an
article in German newspaper or I
wouldn't do it for French but for those
languages that I speak fairly well but
where I can I definitely want to improve
my vocabulary which is a lot of them
even Russian Italians if there are a few
words in there that I don't know I will
definitely bring it into link and you
know you think for them so it really
would only be something like French but
even in Japanese Chinese I can always a
far more vocabulary why don't you do it
I learned first 1,000 characters I've
been through it before but I have a
stack of cardboard flashcards and I
develop to write them out by hand and I
had this sort of squared the paper and I
would write up the first character down
10-15 times and then I would put the
meaning or the sound three columns over
on the squared paper pick up another
card write it and by the third card I
ran into my first meanie and I'd have to
write it again so it's kind of a
primitive spaced repetition system that
I used to acquire the first thousand
characters okay that's it all right
thank you bye for now